- This video is brought to
you by Established Titles.
(ambient music)
What's up, everyone?
Michael, here to ask how much
have you accomplished today?
Whether you ran a
marathon, read Moby-Dick,
or continue the ambitious project
of organically fusing
your butt to the couch,
you might be thinking not nearly enough.
Lately it seems like
everyone feels pressure
to be more productive.
And this craze to get things done
can leave us all feeling like failures.
And on its face, this is kind of ironic.
While we did see a rare slump
and non-farm productivity
earlier this year,
that trend is expected to reverse.
And even though productivity growth
has been smaller in recent years,
American workers are still
working more efficiently
than they were even just
a couple of decades ago.
This makes us wonder why are we all
so obsessed with productivity?
And what's more, is this
obsession actually productive?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack
edition on productivity.
Are we optimizing ourselves to death?
You don't have to search for
#productivity on Instagram
to notice our modern
fixation on overachieving.
For years, books like
"Getting Things Done",
"The Art of Stress-free Productivity"
and "The Four-Hour WorkWeek"
have sold by the millions.
The current productivity
bestseller is "Atomic Habits",
which promises that small, but
meaningful habits can create
staggering changes in your life.
A sales pitch that like
so many of its quadruple
your productivity for fathers,
feels too good to be true.
And if you're too drained
to muster the willpower
to plow through a whole book
about the willpower effect,
rest easy, there are multiple
apps eager to break it down
chapter by chapter in 10 minutes or less.
Look at you go,
getting (beep) done 10 minutes at a time.
The industry of big
productivity has yielded scores
of influencers who espouse their secrets
to logging shorter work weeks,
emptying inboxes, and tripling output.
Every book seems to
have a patented gimmick,
whether it's a productivity pyramid,
a 20-minute routine to
optimize your whole day.
or a list of habits you can
copy from successful people.
The methods behind these
gurus madness vary.
Some suggest outsourcing secretarial tasks
to underpaid workers in
the developing world.
Back in the day, that was
just called colonialism.
Some instruct you to start each day
with the hardest project on your plate,
which it compares to an amphibian.
And one guy from the 1960s
urges you to write your
own gravestone inscription
as a thought experiment to
supposedly gain perspective
on how you're living your life.
My gravestone would say,
"He Died as He Lived,
wondering if the YouTube
comments were right."
If productivity is measured
by how much you accomplish
and how quickly,
it's no wonder that our obsession
with productivity has an
equally sadistic twin,
our obsession with time.
In 1982, physician, Larry Dossey,
dubbed the American fixation
on the second hand of
the clock, time sickness.
And a recent Stanford
study found this fixation
is legitimately bad for our health.
Apparently obsessing over
the time you spend on a task
can increase your stress
levels a whopping 25%.
But skyrocketing cortisol
levels aren't about to stop
the booming productivity
or optimization movement.
Employers are increasingly
turning to digital self-tracking
technologies to monitor
workers' activities,
whether in the form of
digital wellness tools
to encourage employees to walk more,
or computer surveillance programs.
Though, one seemingly exclusive
to the hellscape of Amazon warehouses,
an increasing number of workplaces
are automating technology
to track their workers' productivity,
affecting everyone from
lawyers to accountants.
And wouldn't you know,
they are totally thrilled with this.
No, they're not.
We're just kidding.
They're (beep) miserable.
One financial executive
describes how every minute
of her workday is monitored,
and she literally is
only paid for the minutes
that her computer deems productive.
And yet most Americans
are working more hours
than their parents did,
and as we've established, at
higher rates of productivity,
not to mention lower wages.
So it's worth asking,
why isn't what we're doing just enough?
According to sociologist, Carolyn Chen,
our obsession with always achieving more
is symptomatic of a larger phenomenon.
First scene on a wide
scale in Silicon Valley.
Specifically, Chen argues work is becoming
increasingly central to
our lives and identities,
and has even started to
fill the role of religion.
She writes, "Work has
become a spiritual practice
that inspires religious fervor.
People are not selling
their souls at work.
Rather, work is where
they find their souls."
And if work is akin to
our secular religion,
our productivity is a
measure of our faithfulness.
Companies know this.
In recent years, they've
taken steps to provide
what Chen calls "pastoral
and spiritual care" at work,
from weekly meditation sessions,
to self-fulfillment workshops,
to team building exercises.
Companies are offering
many of the trappings
once associated with spiritual life,
all in the name of
boosting our productivity.
So was the secular religiousafication
of the American workplace inevitable?
Arguably not.
As social researcher, David Frayne writes,
"If work is indeed a central
source of sociality, rights,
status and belonging,
this situation is a social
and historical construction,
and not a fixed feature
of some natural order.
So where does our fixation on our work
and our productivity really come from?
Well, buckle up because
we're about to dive in.
But first, I wanna tell you
about this video sponsor,
Established Titles.
And I also wanna make an
important announcement.
In all future videos,
I will be introducing
myself as Laird Michael,
and that's all thanks
to Established Titles,
which is a project that
lets you buy as little
as one square foot of
dedicated land in Scotland.
And that's enough to earn
you the title of lair.
But Established Titles is
about more than just hooking
you up with a new way to
introduce yourself at parties.
It's also a fun and
effective way to support
Scotland's biodiversity
into a forestation efforts
around the world.
So here's how it works.
First, you purchase your dedicated land
on a private estate in
Eddleston, Scotland.
You'll receive an official
certificate with a crest
along with a unique plot number.
At the same time,
Established Titles will team
up with global charities,
One Tree Planted and Trees for the Future,
to plant a tree in
conjunction with your order.
Established Titles is also a great gift,
because who expects to
hear happy birthday?
Oh yeah, you're a laird now.
Now alternatively, you can
opt for a couples pack,
which ensures a joint in plots of land
for you and your beloved.
And Established Titles told
me that the first 200 people
that purchase a title pack using my link
will effectively be next to my plot,
within a few minutes, walking distance.
Depending on how many of you
wanna become a laird or lady,
we could build our own
little Wisecrack kingdom.
Now Established Titles is
currently running a labor day sale
and you can use code WISECRACK at checkout
to get an additional 10% off your order.
So go to establishedtitles.com/wisecrack,
and get 10% off your
sweet plot Scottish land.
Now back to the show.
Society's have valued
productivity since ancient times.
Philosophers like Aristotle
and Plato spoke admirably about
knowledge-driven achievements
and skilled craftmanship.
But at the same time,
they cautioned that zest
for work should be balanced
with a full throated
embrace of leisure time.
And notably, their mode
work sitting around thinking
for hours on end would
probably be viewed today
as unproductive or naval gazey.
But we don't think so.
Philosophy is hard work,
and someone's got to do it.
But as is the case with
just about everything,
Christianity changed the way
we viewed work when it reframed
labor as a punishment cast
upon the apple curious
by a wrathful God.
As a philosopher, Camillo Berneri writes,
"Ancient and medieval
Catholicism glorified work
mostly as an expedition of sin."
I.e. a reparation for our
spiritual bad behavior.
And once Christians
got gung-ho about work,
criminalizing anybody with a lazy bone
in their body inevitably followed.
In the late middle ages,
idle behavior was treated as a crime,
often punished with a public flogging
followed by forced labor.
And this continued for centuries.
Author, Zuzanna Ladyga, points
out that well into the 1800,
almost identical laws were used in Europe
and the United States in times of crisis
to regulate the distribution
of cheap workforces,
control population mobility,
and stabilize state power.
In America, they were called tramp X,
and violators were forcibly engraved
with intricate horizontal
tattoos on their lower backs.
But while Christianity always valued work,
things went into overdrive in
the 16th and 17th centuries.
Two big things spurred this
productivity happy revolution.
The first was the Protestant Reformation,
which transformed the perception
of work by treating labor,
not as a punishment,
but as a virtuous pursuit in and of itself
to be undertaken with zeal.
Specifically, Calvinists
believed that success
in this lifetime was a sign
of predestined salvation.
So it made sense to hustle your butt off
in order to prove to yourself
and all your buddies that
you were heaven bound.
The second big change was the advancement
of the humble clock.
See, according to
philosopher, George Woodcock,
for most of Western history,
time was conceived of as a
sort of flowing amorphous
ethereal thing and
calculated pretty vaguely.
But the invention of,
and then advancements to the clock
from minute hands around the late 1600
to accurate secondhand
a century or so later,
altered our conception of time.
And consequently, it
altered how much humans felt
they should accomplish during that time.
As Woodcock writes,
"The clock turns time
from a process of nature
into a commodity that can be
measured and bought and sold.
The clock happy post-reformation
world got another boost
from the enlightenment,
which among other things,
valorized mankind's ability
to perform productive labor.
At the time labor was,
"Frequently perceived positively
as a commodity and as a source
of social respectability,"
according to scholar, Deborah Simonton.
At the same time, the west
was undergoing intense
economic growth and expansion.
As markets blossomed,
work became more regimented,
thus time keeping became
linked to industriousness.
Founding father and patron
and sent a to do list,
Benjamin Franklin observed time is money.
One thing on his to-do list
was definitely get syphilis
because he had syphilis.
Simonton explains, "Enlightenment
ideas and burgeoning
entrepreneurship colluded to
improve efficiency and output."
But the joy of an industrious
day's work might not have been
enough on its own to
catapult American culture
into a flurry of productivity.
Sociologist, Max Weber
argues that the rapid rise
of capitalism can be
attributed significantly
to the lingering power of
the Protestant Work Ethic.
Remember the Protestant Work Ethic
conveniently equated economic
success with moral virtue
and no wealthy capitalists
were gonna be mad at that.
The Protestant mindset of
discipline and regulation
also facilitated the expansion
of punitive policies against vagrants,
including mass arrests and forced labor,
which basically just meant
making life hell for vagrants,
wanderers and anyone who
couldn't seem to hold down a job.
That's important because a
big part of valorizing work
has always been about the
elites wanting to keep
the poorest busy
so they wouldn't indulge
in naughty diversions
like drinking or sex.
It's history's favorite
short king, Napoleon wrote,
"The more my people work, the
less vices they will have."
Society's growing fixation on
productivity and demonization
of laziness provided a secular
substitute for the religious
discipline that was
falling out of fashion.
The valorization of work in
America got another big boost
during the Second Industrial Revolution.
A combination of lingering
reformation views,
Victorian morality around work ethic
and delayed gratification,
as well as that all American
ethos of boots strapping
in your way to success all can shield
into a culture of intense industriousness.
It was now every man's duty to work hard
and produce useful things.
And with production speeding up,
thanks to the new fangled
mechanics of everything
from the steamboat to the sewing machine,
workers were quickly transported
from hand making goods at home,
to working in factories.
We talk about this in our
video on working from home.
But this moment in history is important
to today's video too.
Basically, early factory
workers were not exactly
what you'd call well behaved.
They went from making their own hours
at their own homes to being subjected
to grueling endless work days
and unpleasant factories.
Unsurprisingly, absenteeism
was a huge problem.
People were very often drunk on the job,
which despite what they
might have thought,
didn't actually make them funnier.
As historian, Daniel T. Rogers writes,
"By reporting irregularly for work,
moving restlessly from job to job,
or engaging in slowdowns
and work restrictions,
industrial laborers stubbornly resisted
the new work discipline
the factory masters
tried to impose upon them."
Enter mechanical engineer,
Frederick W. Taylor,
who became obsessed with
expediting production processes
in the late 19th century factory,
which basically meant wrangling workers.
He realized that because of
their past as skilled craftsmen,
workers possessed knowledge and dexterity
that actually made them more valuable
than the foreman managing them.
This in Taylor's view was dangerous.
It gave workers way too much power
over the means of production.
So he came up with a way
to increase efficiency
and consolidate control much
higher up the food chain,
all via a new field of study
called scientific management,
which was later dubbed tailorism.
As John Zeerzan writes,
"Scientific management began
to take shape in the 1880s
as the way to break the
workers' threatening resistance.
The heart of this approach
is the systematic reduction
of work into discreet, routinized tasks,
totally separated from any
policy decisions about the job."
Now Adam Smith had conceived
of the assembly line
over a century earlier in his
book, "Wealth of nations."
And such systems had already existed in
American meat packing factories.
But Taylor put this process on steroids,
breaking production into
minuscule individual tasks,
and assigning workers the
same task to do over and over
again at the fastest possible speed,
which is not at all a recipe
for slowly losing your (beep) mind.
As Taylor's methods were widely adopted,
workers went from producing,
say, a shoe or a carriage
at their own pace,
to performing what Rogers calls,
specialized repetitious machine paced
and often deadingly simple actions.
What's more, workers were now
de-skilled and disempowered.
They didn't know how the
wider factory worked.
They only knew how to
perform their specific tasks.
Effectively, the first major methods
of increasing productivity
were largely about
management imposing control on workers.
Taylor's influence was
vast and he wasn't alone.
Other efficiency experts,
most notably Frank and Lilian Gilbreth,
the real family behind
cheaper by the dozen,
sought to expedite productivity.
Specifically by analyzing the (beep)
out of workers' physical movements.
They broke down every work
task into individual motions,
which they call the units of therbligs,
i.e. Gilbert spelled backwards.
They filmed workers
performing acts of labor,
and studied each frame
attempting to cut out
unnecessary motions in
search of what they called
"the one best way of
performing each task".
Notably, Lillian Gilbreth's
work after her husband,
Frank's death was focused on
promoting domestic science,
i.e. bringing the art of
efficiency into the household.
As factories grew more efficient,
the thinking went,
why shouldn't housewives also
benefit from these methods?
Gilbreth and other home
efficiency experts taught women
everything from the best
posture for washing dishes,
to the fastest way to can baby food,
and encouraged them to
find ways to maximize
their efficiency by reducing
the motions required
to perform each task.
Another thing that Gilbert's
realized was that worker
psychology that is their
temperament and contentment
was also essential to productivity.
In what was basically the first
rumbling of human resources,
they encouraged employers to make
workers' surroundings more pleasant.
Provide magazines for them
to read and even set up
suggestion boxes where workers
could make other requests.
The Silicon Valley startups
that feel more like cool coffee
shops than offices have their
roots in this understanding
that happy workers tend
to work harder and faster.
Helped along by tailorism
and the production
needs of two World Wars,
productivity rates in America
began soaring in the 1920s
and continued that trend up into the 70s.
And despite the glaring issues
with treating people like machines,
there seemed to be obvious benefits
to increasing productivity.
As Frayne explains, in
the early 20th century,
business leaders assumed
that the natural results
of improved production techniques
would be an increased in free time.
Economist, John Maynard Kings predicted
that his grandchildren
would work 15-hour weeks.
Kings' prediction seems
naive in hindsight,
but when he was writing
in 1930, it made sense.
After all, production had been
rising in unprecedented 5.3%
a year over the previous decade.
How many buttons and
radios and toothbrushes
could one country need?
And there was precedent for
shortening the work week.
A scour of Benjamin Hunnicutt explains,
in the 1920s, workweeks had
been steadily decreasing
from 70 hours or more in the early 1800,
to a more manageable
50 hours by the 1920s.
And there was reason to
think that newly increased
productivity would lead
to even more leisure time.
But faced with this opportunity
to make their workers' lives happier,
more relaxing, and more fulfilling,
businesses said, actually,
yeah, we're good.
We don't need to do that.
We're just gonna make them keep working.
Why?
As social researcher,
David Frayne explains,
"The idea of a less work and more leisure
was completely counterintuitive
to the dogma of economic growth."
Basically now that they can produce goods
faster and more cheaply,
instead of letting workers take a siesta,
they decided to just produce
a (beep) ton more goods
and maximize profits.
Then there was the whole
more morality side of things.
Rich people don't love it
when poor people have too much free time.
Sigmont Freud even worried that
if labor hours were reduced,
emancipated working class
Americans would fall into
an orgiastic rule of nature
and indulge in their
darkest predilections,
like incest, cannibalism, and murder.
Companies wanted to keep growing
and elites wanted workers
to keep logging long
hours in the factories.
As a result, America was
producing massive quantities
of consumer goods.
So what do you do with a
big surplus of products?
You start hawking that
(beep) via what historian,
Edward S. Cowdrick, dubbed
the new economic gospel
of consumption of the 1920s.
Or as scholar, Kathi Weeks writes,
"Consumption merged as an
essential economic practice.
Producers were expected to do double duty
as aesthetically indulgent consumers."
But how are people supposed
to be good consumers
if they weren't making very much money?
Henry Ford solved that puzzle
when he started paying
his workers $5 a day,
twice the market rate.
While not his primary motivation,
this did have the effect of
making his cars more affordable
to his workers, thus expanding his market.
It was a huge success.
Ford double his profits in just two years.
And this quickly convinced other employers
to follow suit and raise wages.
According to labor
economist, Harley Shaiken,
what that gave us was an
industrial middle class
and an economy that was
driven by consumer demand.
Basically for the first time,
people could buy fun things.
Of course, it's no coincidence
that just as American businesses had way
more products to sell,
we saw the simultaneous
emergence of modern advertising
spurred on by the psychological approach
of Freud's nephew, Edward Bernays.
Advertisements evolved from
their traditional practice
of appealing to people with reason,
i.e. bragging about the high
quality of their toothpaste,
and instead started relying on emotional
and symbolic appeals,
i.e. promising that this
toothpaste will get you laid.
This approach was necessary
because sellers with massive
surpluses were no longer simply catering
to consumers' basic needs.
Now they were creating
entirely new desires.
As Bernays wrote, "Today,
supply must actively seek
to create its corresponding demand.
And cannot afford to wait until
the public asks for its product.
It must maintain constant
touch through advertising
and propaganda to assure
itself the continuous demand."
Such began a virtuous cycle
of people becoming more
productive while earning higher wages.
And thus businesses had
more products to sell,
which they then pedal to their workers,
because they could now
afford to buy (beep) for fun.
So everybody wins and it all worked out.
This is the end of the video.
Of course it's not, it gets bad again.
Now, ever since productivity
became a driving concern
around the turn of the 20th century,
it had mostly been a
top-down process of managers
spurring productivity in their workers
through surveillance,
discipline, and encouragement.
That was about to shift
dramatically in the 50s
and 60s with the rise of knowledge work,
i.e. work that forces you
to think for a living.
Because knowledge work
was more complex, varied,
and nuanced than say, a factory
assembly line of workers
mass producing widgets,
productivity started becoming more
difficult to monitor and to quantify.
This was about to change
the entire way we conceive
of getting stuff done.
At the time, management consultant,
Peter Drucker argued
that personal autonomy
would become the defining feature
of the new knowledge-based corporate world
as individual workers became
responsible for tracking
their own productivity.
He wrote, "The knowledge worker cannot
be supervised closely or in detail.
He must direct himself."
As the impetus fell on individuals
to self-manage their productivity,
many sought advice on how the heck
they were supposed to do that.
Fittingly, this is when
productivity self-help books
first became a fixture
of the book industry.
The trend kicked off
with James McCay's "The
Management of Time" in 1959,
which featured quotes like,
"Tomorrow you promise
yourself will be different,
yet tomorrow is too often
a repetition of today."
Beginning in the 60s,
the productivity guru emerged
as a trustworthy figure offering firm,
but reassuring advice.
Weeks explains that
gurus typically suggest
some kind of reformed
daily routine to insert
ritual awareness into one's day,
much like a religious refrain.
Importantly, the personal
productivity industry
often flourishes during
economic downturns.
In the recession of the mid 1970s,
books like "How to Get
Control of Your Life and Time"
urged anxious workers to make
the most of their coffee break
by learning a new word
from their dictionary.
By the early 90s,
yet another recession had books
like "Self-Discipline in 10 days"
promising to help you go
from thinking to doing.
This literature was serving
an important purpose.
It offered hope for
workers pursuing success
in an increasingly competitive job market,
right as layoffs and corporate downsizing
were becoming the new normal.
And weeks argues that over
the course of the greed
is good 80s, and the
dial-up sound dominated 90s,
"Productivity took on the
thrust of Puritan principles
that could be embraced either adjacent to
or in spite of religious belief
because it holds the same qualities
of disciplined practice."
As productivity solidified itself
as the individual impetus of each worker,
busyness started to be seen as an ideal.
And in recent years,
it's even become an
aspirational status symbol.
According to researcher, Sylvia Plaza.
In pursuit of such status,
we've all become accustomed
to managing our own productivity.
Some of this is circumstantial.
The job market is more
competitive than ever.
Wages haven't kept up with inflation.
Workplace expectations
are at an all time high,
and we're taught to feel
lucky to even have a job.
All these circumstances combined to create
a profound anxiety amongst workers.
And guess what?
That's great for business.
Philosopher, Byang-Chul Han,
explains that anxiety
increases productivity,
while political theorist,
Neil Vallelly adds,
"An anxious subject works harder,
partly at a fear of losing their job."
In short, we're obsessed with
productivity in large part
because, well, we have to be.
We live in a time of intense
precarity and competition.
And the stability of many
career paths is haunted
by ghost of future automation.
Industrial Revolution
era efficiency experts
were mostly concerned with
disciplining workers' bodies
to make them behave more like machines.
But for today's knowledge workers,
Han notes, "Productivity
is not to be enhanced
by overcoming physical resistance
so much as by optimizing
psychic or mental processes."
And now we're the ones
optimizing ourselves.
This is arguably an essential
feature of neoliberalism,
i.e. a liberal capitalist ideology
that emphasizes free markets
and individual responsibility.
As sociologists, Deborah Lupton notes,
neoliberalism tends to
favor soft over hard power.
Writing that, "Instead of
relying on coercive measures
in managing and regulating their citizens,
neoliberal political systems
invest faith in the voluntary
take-up of imperatives by
the citizens themselves.
Citizens believe that certain acts
are in their own best interest
or are integral to ideal selfhood."
She cites productivity
as a prominent imperative
taking up by people in
pursuit of self-betterment.
Han contends that such a fixation
is actually a form of self-oppression.
He writes, "As an entrepreneur of himself,
the neoliberal achievement subject engages
in auto-exploitation willingly,
and even passionately."
As such, he notes, "Perpetual
self-optimization represents
nothing so much as a highly efficient mode
of domination and exploitation.
And in this case he says,
"The psyche itself is being exploited."
So while Taylor had to implement
his time-saving techniques
in a top down way to
wrangle disgruntled, drunk,
and decidedly ungrateful workers,
we now willingly impose Pomodoro Timers,
5:00 AM wake up calls,
and expensive neurotropic
regimens on ourselves.
As such, the worker
becomes what Hong calls
a self-illuminating
self-surveilling subject.
He argues that we're functionally
in a panopticon of our own making,
one where there is no difference
between guard and inmate.
Put differently, the guard
or vigilant manager is living
inside our head rent free.
As we've seen the religious
zeal behind personal
productivity can be
traced all the way back
to capitalism's spiritual
roots and Calvinism,
but as Weeks points out,
today's call to productivity
differs from other religions
because it is entirely inwardly-oriented.
It's a total devotion to one's
self and one's achievement.
And it's a pretty empty ethos.
In our obsession with
maximizing our output,
the actual value of that output
becomes almost irrelevant.
There's no driving
purpose behind the concept
of pure productivity,
other than a very simple market logic
that any production is good production.
As anthropologist, David Graver writes,
"We have become a
civilization based on work,
as an end and meaning in itself."
Graver argues that many of
today's workers are toiling away
at bull (beep) jobs defined
by meaningless work.
In such an environment,
it's no wonder that, as Greg notes,
productivity becomes, "A
framework for knowing what to do
in the absence of a guiding
principle for doing it."
Our quest for productivity
arguably affords us
a sense of control in
a fast paced workplace.
As Greg explains,
"Time management celebrates
command and control.
The idea of time sovereignty
holds faith in the idea
that time is territory
that can be conquered."
We can't do anything about
next month's layoffs,
but (beep) damn it, we
can milk every last second
out of our workday.
Conquering time comforts us
in an era of profound insecurity.
We feel an affirming twang
of self-determination
every time we skip lunch
with our work piles
to eat at our desk.
In this way,
Greg sees time management
as inherently isolating.
"A form of training through
which workers become
capable of the evermore
daring acts of solitude
and ruthlessness necessary to
produce career competence."
And all of this focus on our
own productivity has the effect
of distracting us from the
very reasons we're pushed
to be so productive in the first place.
As Han writes,
"Even class struggle has transformed
into an inner struggle against oneself."
When we're pushing ourselves
to be more productive,
we're not questioning or
agitating against the systems
that have allowed America's
sweeping productivity gains
to mostly flow to the top.
Instead, we're trying to
control our circumstances
by controlling our brains,
kind of feels like trying to
stop the Titanic from sinking
by making sure that
your personal life fest
is on real tight.
In this way,
the culture of productivity
is inherently alienating.
As Greg notes,
Productivity's inward focus
further entrenches the erasure
of collective thinking that
the first efficiency engineers
sought to accomplish."
Just as Taylor took the
factories' collective production
processes and divided it
into individual tasks,
our contemporary
productivity obsession makes
corporate success a matter
of individual responsibility.
And then it pits those
individuals against one another.
As philosopher, Pierre Bourdieu observes,
under neoliberalism,
competition that once existed
between say, two competing corporations,
has increasingly shifted to competition
amongst individuals within the same firms.
Today, your real rival
is just one cubicle over.
At the same time,
the atomized nature of modern work culture
perpetuates another neoliberal truism,
that any individual's failures
come from their own moral
or intellectual shortcomings.
Han argues that, "People who fail
in the neoliberal achievement-society
see themselves as
responsible for their lot
and feels shame instead of questioning
society or the system."
Maybe your ADHD makes keeping
up with hundreds of emails
a day in insurmountable challenge.
Maybe your dyslexia makes
copy editing legal documents
a slow and laborious task.
Or maybe you're just bored of
spreadsheets and bureaucracy
and stupid corporate jargon.
Damn, you sound pretty lazy.
So don't come knocking on my
door, asking for handouts.
In sum, anyone who doesn't commit to fully
optimizing themselves
is seen as inadequate,
even delinquent.
As graver notes,
"We've come to believe that
men and women who do not work
harder than they wish at jobs
they do not particularly enjoy
are bad people unworthy of love, care,
or assistance from their communities.
It is as if we have
collectively acquiesced
to our own enslavement."
So hows an overly productive
society supposed to cope?
Recently an influx of new books
like Jenny, Odell's "How to Do Nothing",
have squarely taken on
productivity culture.
Odell argues that cultivating
decidedly unproductive practices,
in her case, spending time
at parks watching birds,
is a crucial step in taking
back our own attention,
and building forms of resistance
to capitalism's limitless
drive for production.
This argument suggests
that, as Weeks puts it,
"There is a value of non-work
time as a resource for social,
cultural, and political
projects of transvaluation."
That is to say we have to
take time off from work
in order to have the time to
question whether work should be
our highest priority in the first place.
Scholar, Brian O'Conner
furthers this point,
arguing that there's a profound freedom
in preserving idle time
explicitly not defined by achievement.
He argues that idleness
is, "An implicit resistance
to specific recommendations
about how one ought to live:
The need for progress, prestige,
or success through work.
And it is also the
pleasure that we experience
when we are free to live
Without those expectations."
Maybe we could learn a thing or two from
all those day drunk
factory workers after all.
But if being idle for even
a minute sounds awful,
Greg proposes a different way
to radicalize productivity culture.
She writes that we need
to move our aspirations
for productivity from the corporate
to the collective interest.
Productive atmospheres
are truly revolutionary
when they initiate a form
of collective solidarity
that is not dependent on labor."
And that sounds suspiciously
similar to something Amazon
and Starbucks workers are
currently fighting for.
Now arguably, personal
productivity is an internalization
of the obsessive growth mindset
that is long dominated
American economic life.
We should produce not
because it's valuable,
but because we can.
But just as dissenters have
reacted to productivity culture
on an individual level,
we see a similar tide
rising on a societal level
with the emergence of
the degrowth movement.
Drawing on ecoliberalism,
which seeks to balance individualism
and industry with ecological concerns,
degrowth advocates argue
that pursuing unchecked
economic growth is antithetical
to protecting the planet
from environmental catastrophe.
They advocate for vastly
ramping down production
and consumption and prioritizing
social and ecological wellbeing instead.
As economic anthropologist,
Jason Hickel writes,
"We need to slow it all down.
Slow down the mad pace of
extraction, production, and waste,
and slow down the mad pace of our lives."
In this way, the de-growth
movement compels us
to also question our personal
fixation on productivity,
which is really just the atomized version
of society's ceaseless growth mindset.
And this seems like a healthy thing to do,
because if productivity culture
isn't making us happier,
and if endlessly growing production
is slowly destroying the planet,
perhaps it's time to think
a little less about getting
things done and a little more
about getting things right.
But what do you all think?
Is productivity culture toxic
or just a harmless quest
for self improvement?
And are we all still just
Protestant Work Ethicing
in ourselves to death?
Let us know in the comments.
Be sure to like the video
to tell us that we
worked hard enough on it.
Shout out to our patrons
for all their support.
Do check out our Patreon page
if you have it in a while.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)